hi guys and rawls from simply learn and
today I'm going to tell you how you can
become a digital marketer so here's what
we'll be going through today first off
who is a digital marketer how to become
a digital marketer the salary of a
digital marketer and how you can become
a certified digital marketer so first
off let's answer the most important
question who is a digital marketer now a
digital marketer is responsible for
several things let's go through some of
them first off they're responsible to
develop as well as managed marketing
campaigns to ensure that the goals of
the organization of fulfilled they need
to create a marketing strategy which is
based on analyzing their competition as
well as the benchmarks within the
industry they need to drive website
traffic as well as acquire lease which
are then worked upon by the organization
or the business they need to utilize web
analytics tools so that they can measure
and optimize the campaign which is
basically figuring out how well the
campaign is doing and if it's not doing
well how they can make it better and
finally they need to be able to enhance
brand awareness which is just letting
people know that the brand exists and
how the brand can make their lives
better next up let's talk about how to
become a digital marketer to become a
digital marketer you need a certain set
of skills skills like search engine
optimization search engine marketing or
SEM email marketing social media
marketing affiliate marketing content
marketing and finally mobile marketing
so the first step you need to take to
become a digital marketer is to learn
SEO so SEO or search engine optimization
is the process of increasing the quality
of your organic traffic which is nothing
but the traffic that comes to your
website without having seen any paid
advertisements just because your website
is one of the first few results when
they search a particular query on a
search engine
SEO involves on-page SEO as well as off
page SEO so how to do on-page SEO
first off you need to do keyword
research keyword research is one of the
most important steps when it comes to
SEO it is the process of identifying
popular words and phrases used on search
engines by users you need to be able to
identify keywords with high search
volume high irrelevancy and low
competition
next up we have technical audit so
search engines around the world have
internet bots performing a particular
process known as crawling in this
process these search engine internet
bots these search engine BOTS also known
as spiders scanner website and copy the
entire website's content and store it
within the search engine for it to index
now you need to ensure your site is
being crawled and indexed next you have
on site optimization you need to develop
high quality content
meta tags URL and sitemaps and finally
user experience you need to provide good
website architecture as well as internal
linking structure next up let's talk
about how to do off page SEO this is
made possible with the help of link
building this is the process of
navigating links from other websites to
your own and by building external links
to your website your organic search
ranking can be improved now let's talk
about some SEO tools you have Moz Google
Keyword planner
SEMRush and EHRs now let's talk about
the next step required to become a
digital marketer which is to learn SEM
or search engine marketing search engine
marketing is a practice of marketing a
business using paid advertisements on
search engines and other websites so
basically this is a way of attracting
users towards your website or a
particular product that you are offering
so how can you do SEM or search engine
marketing first off you need to
determine your goal and define a budget
you need to ensure that you have a goal
in mind for example do you want more
leads do you want to increase traffic or
improve brand awareness and much more
after you're done with that you need to
define a budget how much money are you
ready to spend to achieve this goal then
you need to choose a list of relevant
keywords which is keywords on which you
be bidding to advertise you need to
finalize your keywords and then bid on
them which is basically are you ready to
pay for how many clicks you're getting
or for acquiring customers or making
them leads and so on you need to create
a compelling headline for your ad
campaign you need to monitor the
performance of campaigns and measure
results which is basically finding out
whether the campaign is working out well
and if it's not to optimize it so that
it works the next time and you need to
target your audience with 3 marketing
campaigns for
if a customer does not go through with
the conversion process they can be added
to the remarketing audience so that they
can be advertised to again some of the
popular SCM tools are google adwords
editor FB ads manager Bing ads and ad
roll now for the next step to become a
digital marketer you have to learn email
marketing now email marketing is really
efficient as well as inexpensive way to
generate high return on investment it
can be used to convert prospects into
customers by sending personalized emails
to a targeted audience so how do you
perform email marketing first off you
need to discover your target audience
and create segments in which you can
divide them depending on their behavior
you need to select and create your type
of campaign depending on the goals you
want to achieve you need to select a
suitable design for your campaign you
need to have a compelling subject line
and email content which is very
important when it comes to email
marketing you need to send campaigns
immediately or schedule an email and
finally you need to measure results such
as open rate click-through rate response
rate and so on you also need to perform
a be testing to find out what works and
what doesn't some of the popular email
marketing tools are MailChimp HubSpot
market o send in blue and so on and now
for the next step you need to learn
social media marketing social media
marketing involves the promotion of your
products and services on different
social media platforms using different
types of content now this could be just
sponsored posts video advertisements
images articles and so on now how can
you do social media marketing first off
you need to choose a suitable social
media platform for your business it
could be Facebook YouTube Twitter
Linkedin and so on next up you need to
find your target audience now each of
these platforms has a particular niche
that occupies it now for example
Facebook requires an active social media
marketing strategy Pinterest is usually
used by females LinkedIn can be used for
employee networking and YouTube is a
platform where people create as well as
share video content and that's the only
content that works on YouTube you need
to create as well as curate engage in
content because without your content
being engaging nobody's going to be
interested in your product or service
you need to choose a social media
management tool and finally you need to
test evaluate and optimize your results
now let's talk about some popular social
media marketing tools we have HootSuite
tweet tech buffer sprout social and so
many more now for your next step to
becoming a digital marketer you need to
learn affiliate marketing now affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves two players a merchant as
well as an affiliate now much it is an
individual who pays a commission do they
feel it who could be a third party site
or entity to drive sales bring leads or
new customers with the help of reference
now how can you do affiliate marketing
first off you need to choose a tool
through which you can find affiliates
who can advertise your product now you
need to choose affiliate on the basis of
how much traffic the affiliates website
gets how successful the affiliates
previous campaigns where and and how
much Commission the affiliate asks for
then you need to specify the format that
the affiliate must use when they're
advertising your product or service you
need to keep a record of the customers
who purchased your product or service
through the affiliate and finally pay
the affiliate based on the commission
rates now let's talk about some of the
popular affiliate marketing tools there
CJ affiliate volume has offers and even
now for the next step to becoming a
digital marketer you need to learn
mobile marketing now mobile marketing
enables a business to communicate with
the targeted audience through any mobile
device this is through SMS emails Emma
masses and so on so how do you do mobile
marketing first off you need to create a
mobile buyer persona which is you know
what kind of person is using the phone
you need to set business goals like what
goals basically determining what goals
you want to achieve with the mobile
marketing campaign then you need to
conduct your campaign and reach your
target audience with a personalized
message to these users and finally you
need to monitor these metrics and
optimize them if required now let's talk
about some popular mobile marketing
tools there's slicktext Localytics AdMob
Facebook mobile ads and much more now
for your next step in becoming a digital
marketer you need to learn content
marketing content marketing is a
marketing technique of creating as well
as sharing valuable content now this
could be blogs videos or articles which
solves a problem of the target audience
this holds their attention by adding
value to their lives and can end up
converting their interest into a
purchase so how do you do content
marketing firstly you need to define
your goals as in what you want to
achieve you need to define your target
audience then you needed to mine what
kind of content you are creating it
could be blog posts ebooks case studies
infographics and so on you need to
brainstorm for new content ideas you
need to perform a Content audit which is
to evaluate content elements and
information assets and choose a suitable
content management system now you can
plan create publish and measure your
results all in one place using a content
management system using a content
management system such as the HubSpot
software next you need to promote your
content using email affiliate and social
media marketing finally you need to
measure your success and optimize your
content now let's talk about some of the
popular content marketing tools there's
LinkedIn pulse paper dot Li Flipboard
trap it and many many more now let's
talk about some additional resources now
there is a huge number of videos online
about digital marketing and I recommend
you go through some of them so that you
have a basic idea about the fundamentals
now this is where simply owns YouTube
channel can help you you can take
advantage of simply learn digital
marketing tutorials you can go to this
playlist right here and here you have
tutorials on what is SEO how you can
rank number one on google keywords
research Facebook ads tutorial how you
can rank your YouTube videos Facebook
advertising tips and tricks social media
marketing Google tag manager Google
Analytics and so much more now let's
have a look at the salaries of a digital
marketer in the United States the
average salary of a digital marketer is
approximately 65 thousand dollars per
year similarly the average salary for a
digital marketer in India is
approximately 5 lakh rupees per year now
let's talk about how you can become a
certified digital marketer now there are
a number of different certifications
available for you there's the Google Ads
fundamental certification the Facebook's
are
planning professional certification the
HubSpot content marketing certification
the HootSuite social marketing
certification and simply learns digital
marketing specialists master's program
now here's another way simple and can
help you simply learn has a number of
different digital marketing
certification has a number of different
digital marketing certifications let's
talk about the digital marketing
specialist master's program in this
program there are a number of different
certifications such as the digital
marketing certified associate advanced
web analytics advanced SEO and so on the
certification also provides the Oh mCP
certification exam voucher worth three
hundred ninety five dollars upon the
completion of the master's program it
has 45 plus projects and can help you
get a salary of close to 17 lakhs per
annum
it is also accredited by HootSuite
Facebook the OU MCP and so on so now
let's have a closer look at the digital
marketing course or the digital
marketing certified associate
certification training now this
certification provides 53 hours of
instructor led training 40 plus hours of
self-paced videos instructor-led online
project mentoring sessions helping you
prep for examinations from the om CA
Google Ads and so on
it has industry accreditations from
HootSuite Facebook and the om CP and it
covers more than 35 tools such as
Facebook Insights YouTube analytics
crazy a Google Keyword planner Google ad
manager and LinkedIn ads buffer semrush
and so on so why don't you go on to
simply learn calm so that you can so
that you can get started on your journey
getting certified and getting ahead and
with that we've reached the end of this
video I hope you found this video
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here